there obviously is an ongoing campaign
by some
radicals to basically indoctrinate your
kids in their version of sexual values
the biggest problem is that this sort of
radical position
is becoming quite mainstream across the
land you're seeing public school
educators who have decided that if you
teach your kids traditional biblical
values
uh with regard to sexuality for example
that this is a form of indoctrination
and that you are a bad parent that if
you don't teach your kids about gender
fluidity that if you don't teach your
kids
about the exact moral equivalent between
different forms of sexual activity
then this means that you are somehow
depriving your children and this has
driven the radicals to
new depths today's story courtesy of
daily wire
parents in new york city's elite private
dalton school have come out in force
against videos dealing with the topic of
masturbation that were shown to their
first grade children
parents who sent their kids to the 55
000 a year school have bombarded the
school with complaints
about dalton director of health and
wellness justine ang fonte's curriculum
the new york post reported
fonte showed six-year-olds a cartoon
during her sex ed class that featured a
sm that featured small
children discussing touching themselves
because it feels good here's what that
cartoon sounded like
how come my penis gets big sometimes and
points up in the air
that's called an erection sometimes i
touch my penis because it feels good
sometimes when i'm in my bath or when
mom puts me to bed
i like to touch my vulva too you have a
clitoris there kayla that probably feels
good to touch the same way
keith's penis feels good when he touches
it but have you ever noticed that older
kids and grown-ups don't touch their
private parts in public
hmm they don't that's right keith
it's okay to touch yourself and see how
different body parts
feel but it's best to only do it in
private
i mean first of all i just have a
question since we're and that seems kind
of judgmental to me
i mean so long as they're teaching kids
about masturbation in first grade
i don't see why it should only be in
private i mean shouldn't we learn from
the innocence of the children
and truly if you're on the radical left
and you believe that this sort of stuff
should be taught to the children
why i mean really isn't that why are you
teaching them shame
are you kink shaming these children the
bizarre perversity of teaching this to
first graders is beyond me but
let's be real about this i don't think
sex ed should be taught in public school
classrooms at all
i think they should be learning biology
like basic human biology would be good
we have schools that are churning out
kids who don't know basic reading or
math
but you're going to let these
teachers somehow teach your children
about sexual values
makes perfect sense sounds great
about 120 juniors girls and boys at
columbia grammar and prep school
were subjected to fonte's class called
pornography literacy
an intersectional focus on mainstream at
porn because she she taught
at an elite manhattan school for high
school students
so that's great teaching high school
students about an intersectional focus
on mainstream porn i mean you do need to
make sure that kids are
when they're focusing on their uh on
their spank material you have to make
sure that they are really focused on
intersectionality
because every act of sexuality is an act
of rebellion against the status quo gang
fonte's class included material such as
semi-nude women in bondage porn genres
including incest themes barely legal
and kink and bdsm and the most searched
pornography terms of 2019.
the head of dalton school jim best
announced last month he was stepping
down to focus on other exciting and
inspiring opportunities as the school
weathers criticism
from parents but again this is just an
extreme version
unfortunately of the kind of stuff that
is routinely taking place
in schools around the country where kids
are being taught that if you have any
sort of traditional values with regard
to sex it's because you are judgmental
and it's because you haven't come to
grips with your with your own
your own body and all this kind of crap
take your kid
out of the school right now take your
kids out of these schools right
right right now the battle for the
culture is heating up we here at the
daily wire are making some big moves so
be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment